winter is coming whether these
characters are ready for it or not the
door Game of Thrones season 6 episode 5
reminder I don't you spoiled a friend
anymore and this you know what I
declared the previous episode to be the
highlight of the season so far and this
one managed to top it how good was it it
managed to take things that are
fundamental problems with the aspects of
the story being doubled at this point
and still made them work an example of
that you're on Greyjoy this guy came out
of nowhere a couple of episodes ago
we've never seen this guy before we
never even heard of this guy before that
I can remember I should be annoyed that
he's coming in and taking over the story
and yanking it away from characters who
we know and Weavin been invested in
spent time with but the the guy playing
him is charismatic enough and sells the
part well enough and the people around
him sell their side of it well enough
that i still dunk it i dug what he did I
dug the way he sold it I dug just fun
kind of find out more about the Ironborn
just some cutthroat they are as a people
Sansa after years years of waiting for
her to step up this this is what I
wanted when she walks in there and she
just throws everything at little finger
every bit that he put her through and
that his machinations caused her to
endure she spits it right back at him
and I love the look on his face it's
actually even possible that he was kind
of hurt to hear and not be able to sort
of turn away from what it is that she
was put through and if it didn't
genuinely hurt him good but between
santa and her line delivering the thing
she's had a brand right behind her with
just that that scowl oh she was so ready
to cut him into if Sansa said the word
and I didn't need her tag to order his
death but I love that she could have
dinero's doesn't get much to do but she
gives her Jorah such a wonderful send
off and I actually I found that really
touching because I kind of chalked it up
to it
jarrah had sort of assumed he was going
to do who's gonna wander off till the
condition got too bad and then he was
gonna kill himself and she orders him to
find a cure I love that in doing that
not only is she saying I'm not giving up
on you even though I know it's hopeless
she gave him a purpose with whatever
time he has left he now has a mission
and he's gonna try and fulfill it I
doubt he'll pull it off though maybe
maybe you know last episode of the last
season he'll show up I don't know where
it cured and you know what I'll be fine
with that I don't need that davon cuz
this in and of itself just knowing that
she gave him a purpose for however much
longer he's got left that was really
nice I liked it the stuff going on in
marine almost didn't quite work for me
that you know with Tyrion and this other
woman who's I'd acted odd serves the
Lord of Light I did I get thrown off
trying to figure out the name of that
religion sometimes anyways that seemed
it was ok wasn't doing much for me a
devil she started talking to Varys and
just to see Varys get disarmed and
caught off guard and not know what to
say that doesn't happen that never
happens and it turned into a little bit
like that seen with your own Greyjoy
over on the Iron Islands and the just
this thing that shouldn't work but they
found though just the right angle and
they twisted the screw it just the right
point that suddenly it started to work
and it clicked and I wasn't bored or
frustrated or annoyed with the scene
which is something that I easily could
have been if they hadn't had just that
little bit extra are ya I'm really
curious as to where she's gonna go with
this thing I whether or not she's gonna
do this kill I'm I'm kind of crossing my
fingers that she won't because there was
just something about the fact that she
saw this woman she's like there's
nothing wrong with her she doesn't
deserve to die and it's a reminder that
the Faceless Men you know for all their
we serve the many-faced God they also
just do whatever job they get hired for
and Arya got into this thing in the
pursuit of righteous justice I mean
blood vengeful righteous justice but she
wanted to punish people who deserved
that's why she pursued this in the first
place and I'm hoping she keeps out of
that and then she is able to break away
from them
at this point I don't want her to go
full bore into becoming one of the
Faceless Men just because that I don't
want to lose her as a character and I
feel like that's what would have to
happen I mean they say you can't be re
you have to be no one I want her to be
aria and I feel like we've now seen the
hint of what would be the reason why she
can't go through with it and I am kind
of hoping for that for her but then
we've got our big finish with brand the
three-eyed Raven the children and the
White Walkers now the whole thing with
the warring and how it's kind of working
and how I think it's kind of working
anyway he's interesting in the first
place and you know we've had our hints
that when he goes back into the past
he's not just observing that he can
somehow impact it that he has some kind
of presence there and you know we get
that initially with the night's king
obviously seeing him touching him now he
can come and get him and they show up
admit I was so tense cuz I remember
thinking okay I don't think they can
kill brand he's too important like
pivotal plot wise and we're too close to
the end of the series overall they can't
kill him but man that whole time was
like oh my god what is gonna happen and
we love we lost another direwolf I think
we're down to two now I think we've got
ghosts and I'm area and I don't think
they're ever gonna bring back nightmare
Oh i lo side note we did finally find
out what's going on with black fish and
he'll finally come back thank you only
took you three years to tie up that
loose thread anyways getting back as I
said it was wonderfully intense and you
reminded me actually a lot of aliens you
know whether they're climbing in through
the vents in the ceiling is sort of
climbing upside down it's even got sort
of the similar sacrificial you know
grenade death to stop them and Hodor man
talk about playing the long game to pay
off a character but wow did that work
and I figured out the instant that her
voice in the past said hold the door and
you'd saw his face and I went oh my god
they just let it play out and they just
let us stand and I don't know man they
give I mean I'm like hoo daur I've
always liked told her but he's not a
character you get overly most you get
affectionate towards but there's no
reason that moment should have played
powerfully as it did but man it it just
hits in this idea of this this thing
that we're gonna watch him die doing
this is the only thing he's been meant
to do since he was a teenager and that's
bizarre and that's sad and that's tragic
and yet oddly heroic and it's it's
perfect for Game of Thrones it really
just is so i am just I'm really excited
with the so far and I'm excited for the
next episode although also slightly
nervous I get nervous when a seasoned
appears to be peeking this early on like
can they sustain momentum for another
five episodes I don't know but I hope so
and I am excited to come back and see it
so the door your thoughts whatever you
think drop something down in the
comments and let's talk about it don't
forget to Like subscribe check me out on
Twitter I council of geeks check out the
council of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned